today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
alright guys i am now ready to say on
the
heels of the confirmation of donald
trump's nominee to the supreme court
amy coney barrett that joe biden and
democrats if given
the opportunity must expand
the supreme court of course this depends
on taking the white house
taking the senate keeping control of the
house of representatives
i'm going to be calling it expanding the
court rather than packing the court
when you say packing the court you're
already seating
some ground to the right and making it
sound like something outrageous or
radical or aggressive when it's not
i've made it very clear that on moral
questions
the left must not stoop down to where
the right is when it comes to dishonesty
and authoritarianism and the perversion
of justice but when it comes to using
the systems we have
to legally fight against double
standards
and hypocrisy and absurdity we actually
have a responsibility to do it so let's
go through and talk about it piece by
piece
there are some on the right who say
adding justices to the supreme court
would be a crazy unprecedented
authoritarian undemocratic thing for a
hypothetical
president joe biden to do this is
completely untrue
john adams reduced the size of the court
from six to five
thomas jefferson went back from five to
six and subsequently up to seven
under andrew jackson the court went from
seven to nine justices so the idea that
it's not something that has been done
is wrong now there are some even on the
left who oppose expanding the supreme
court
because of the slippery slope
possibility
that if joe biden expands the court the
next republican
faced with a uh a minority
on their side on the court will then
expand the court again
and then the next democratic spans the
court again and on and on and on
first of all this is silly at its face
because at a certain point how big is
the court going to get 97 justices
131 justices it's not going to happen
okay because the public wouldn't
actually stand for it and i'm going to
get back to that momentarily
but importantly expanding the court
is not actually that easy if you have
the same party controlling the white
house the senate and the house
which we could have from 2021 to 2023
if democrats take the white house and
and the senate
expanding the court is not that
different from passing
an appropriations bill but there are two
reasons why it's unlikely that we would
go in this slippery slope direction of
indefinite expansion of the supreme
court
and the first is it's not actually that
common
that the same party controls the white
house the house and the senate
at a time when the public would be okay
with an expansion of the court barack
obama
had the white house house and senate for
two out of his eight years
and it's very common that at least
one of those three is controlled by an
opposing party
but maybe more importantly there are
many political circumstances that don't
lend themselves to public approval of
expanding the court
and if the circumstances don't lend
themselves to expanding the court
and a republican or democratic
controlled
house senate and white house decides to
do it when the public isn't
uh in the mode that they believe it is
appropriate
they will be punished electorally if
donald trump is defeated and democrats
take the senate
and and uh we retain control of the
house
it will be one of those times where the
public will be okay with expanding
the court because the public knows the
absurdity of the last four years the
public knows the ridiculous double
standard of republicans saying
no merrick garland during the last year
of barack obama's term
but yes amy coney barrett in the last
week
of donald trump's term the urgent need
to right that wrong i believe will give
us
a population from 2021 to 2023
that would be okay with an expansion of
the court if indeed democrats take the
senate and the white house
so not only is there nothing
unconstitutional about expanding the
court
not only is there nothing unprecedented
about expanding the court
not only is there nothing set in stone
that one expansion will inevitably lead
to every future president expanding the
court but if joe biden wins the white
house and democrats take the senate we
will have a unique two-year period
during which the country will understand
that to get back
on a more correct path we must take
less common actions and one of those
actions
is expanding the court to get it back
from these
outrageous lunatics that donald trump
has put on the court
and for those saying that while it may
not be unconstitutional
and it may not be undemocratic the
reality is
it is actually democratic republicans
have nominated
i'm sorry i said that wrong for those
saying it might not be unconstitutional
but it is undemocratic
understand that republicans have
nominated 15 of the last 19 justices
despite having lost the popular vote in
six of the last seven presidential
elections
that doesn't sound democratic to me if
you disagree with me
let me know i want to hear from you this
story
is just the height of the full
logical conclusion to donald trump
continuing to hold his rallies with no
regard whatsoever for the attendees
public health this doesn't even have to
do with coronavirus
donald trump did three rallies yesterday
the third was in omaha nebraska
at roughly 9 pm eastern time i covered
it live
it was sort of cold and there's also a
pandemic going on now just based on the
pandemic before i get to the cold
this was a bad idea just looking at
cases in nebraska
the curve is spiking it's not good it's
a terrible idea to continue holding
these rallies this one was packed
with reportedly six thousand people
shoulder to shoulder very few masks
even the people on stage behind trump
widely not wearing masks
trump said there were 29 000 people
there that was a lie but there were 6
000 people and that's way too many
for when you have a global hundred year
pandemic but that's the case at every
rally
last night there was the added
humiliation for donald trump
which was that it was cold and donald
trump wrapped up quickly actually one of
the shortest rallies he's given
in this campaign yesterday because it
was cold and trump flew out on air force
one
to i think it was uh wherever he was
overnighting maybe las vegas or
something like that
the temperature dropped to nearly
freezing rally goers started lining up
to get their bus rides back to their
parking lots four miles away but the
buses weren't there
the buses couldn't get in because
outbound traffic from the airport
where they held the rally occupied both
the inbound
and the outbound lanes all traffic was
going out buses couldn't get in
and for hours attendees including older
folks
just stood there police had no idea what
to do
some groups started walking miles on the
sides of the road i mean it became
almost post-apocalyptic and then the
hypothermia 9-1-1 calls
started people were stranded police were
saying we need
30 buses here now can you imagine and if
you look at the tweets monitoring the
omaha the omaha police scanner
you start seeing reports of medics
treating parties
police requesting incident command to
put people in a warehouse because people
are freezing
we need more medics we have one medic
treating four people calls flying in
about
elderly folks needing assistance eight
to nine elderly people struggling
elderly party unable to move with
altered mental status elderly male
down trump by continuing to hold these
ego boosting rallies his ego
created a dystopian post-apocalyptic
scenario i actually recently read a
really great novel
called station 11. it's by uh canadian
author i believe emily st
john mandel and it is actually a
post-pandemic dystopian
novel and there are exactly these scenes
people walking miles
into or out of airports with no
transportation
in the book it's because there's no more
fuel uh here it's a different scenario
this is what trump created last night
with his ill-advised rally
all to feed his ego and when i saw this
i thought to myself
you know the only reason we have low
temperatures is because we have so many
thermometers if we could
we're only finding freezing temperatures
because we keep
checking the temperature with the
thermom you know where i'm going with
that anyway as i've said before
these rallies don't convince people if
you are
so deluded and out there to even
go to one of these rallies during a
hundred year pandemic
you're voting for trump regardless and
this is all about
feeding donald trump's ego and just
imagine devoting yourself
to any one person the way these people
have devoted themselves to trump
never mind to somebody who is actually
like donald trump who couldn't care less
about all of these people now if we do
our jobs
these rallies end forever in six days
if we don't then these rallies probably
continue and slide directly into trump
doing rallies for who knows maybe one of
his kids
who will run for the republican
nomination in 2024. so there's a lot
riding
on the next six days uh let's keep it
going
let's do the right thing early voting
numbers look good
but the polling among those still
waiting to vote
look good for trump so let's not assume
anything at all in any state
keep it going let me know how voting is
going in your state in your town in your
precinct
i'm on twitter at deepakman we'll take a
quick break and we have so much more
to discuss today the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's
exactly what one of my favorite apps
lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our program is mostly
supported by
individual memberships which you can
find at joinpakman.com
and for the next six days only you can
use the coupon code 2020 now
to get 66 percent off of the
membership of your choice at
joinpackman.com
i want to be really clear as i talk
about this next story
the most important part of this election
is removing donald trump and replacing
him with joe biden
so that we can start to get the country
back on the right path the country has
been taken over by lunatic extremists
and ignorant clowns in washington dc
corrupt fools and delusional narcissists
this is not about even republicans and
democrats
i'll be having a conversation today with
the conservative douglas murray
about actual conservatism this is
something very different this has been a
coup of incompetence which must be
remedied it's
dangerous it's creepy it's disgusting it
has to be fixed for the sake of all of
our futures
but in addition to that watching donald
trump
increasingly triggered by former
president barack obama's speeches
has really been a delight last week
barack obama rallied for joe biden in
philadelphia pennsylvania
over the weekend barack obama rallied
for joe biden in miami florida
and every time trump starts tweeting
conspiracies about barack obama attacks
on barack obama because he's just so
jealous
of barack obama and yesterday barack
obama was in orlando florida for joe
biden and again
just hammering trump in exactly the way
that most
gets to trump and trump's insecurities i
really think obama is going to make
trump explode
by election day at this rate check this
out here is barack obama going right
after trump
on something trump is very insecure
about which is the
size of trump's crowds which
is of course so meaningless but it just
goes to the heart
of donald trump's narcissism any
interest in doing the work
or helping anybody but himself and his
friends
or treating the presidency as anything
more than a reality show
that can give him the attention that he
craves and he does crave attention
this week with everything that's
happening you know what he brought up
he was fussing about the crowd size at
the inauguration again
saying his was bigger i
who who who is thinking about that
right now nobody except him
another theme is that trump either tries
to undo
what barack obama did or tries to take
credit for it it's one or the other
either undo it or claim that you
actually did it
and again barack obama going right to
the heart of that by talking about jobs
numbers which did
slow down when donald trump became
president of the united states
that complicated donald trump
likes to claim he built this economy but
i just want to remind you that
america created 1.5 million more jobs
in the last three years of the obama
biden administration
than in the first three years of the
trump pence
administration that's a fact look it up
it is a fact and i do encourage you to
look it up and of course
any reasonable person understands that
there is much more
complexity than merely obama was better
at job creation than trump but
it is true those are the numbers and
donald trump can't handle that and he
hates that and he lies about it
and then this is just great barack obama
addressing donald trump's claim
that he's been the best president for
black people
since abraham lincoln even better than
the actual black
president take a look at this and he
wants to take credit for it says he's
the best president for black folks since
abe lincoln
man now his advisors are out there
saying
including his son-in-law his son-in-law
says black folks have to want to be
successful
that's the problem
who are these folks what history books
do they read who do they talk to
don't read is that what is going on and
[Laughter]
what wild times we live in huh and then
lastly here barack obama going after
donald trump
for being enamored uh with global
dictators
and authoritarians saying of course they
want trump to win
and over donald trump being so triggered
by leslie stahl
from his 60 minutes interview our
current president he whines that 60
minutes is too tough
you think he's going to stand up to
dictators he thinks leslie stalls a
bully
just yesterday just yesterday
he said that putin of russia
she of china and kim jong-un of north
korea
want him to win we know
we know because you've been giving them
whatever you want
for the last four years of course they
want you to win
that's not a good thing we'll talk a
little bit more about leslie stahl
momentarily but
really just finely tuned to get to
donald trump
and to throw trump off balance and of
course
these are not highly substantive policy
rallies that barack obama is doing
although they have more substance than
trump's
but they don't have to be this is barack
obama this isn't the candidate this is a
surrogate
in this case a surrogate for joe biden
who's going out
as a popular person within the party to
fire up the base and really hitting the
right notes to trigger donald trump
and boy has it worked now am i childish
for thoroughly enjoying when barack
obama does this
am i uh is it infantile for me to relish
obama taking the gloves off and taking
these shots at trump
because it angers trump more than
anything i care about policy and we've
taken
uh biden's policy on taxes and done a
deep dive as economic policy energy
policy
climate policy the whole thing and that
really matters
but isn't this great in some way and
importantly
a really important message on voting
from barack obama yesterday and this is
why i think it's great
for him to be doing these rallies at all
barack obama said we can't be complacent
we were complacent last time and look
what happened
and by the way i think he should also be
saying those people on the
i know he won't say it i say it the
people on the left who said
hillary trump it's all the same they're
both neoliberal shills or
tools of the establishment look at the
supreme court my friends look at the
supreme court
uh and the real key here is as barack
obama says
no complacency six days to go the latest
numbers
on early and mail-in voting as of this
morning
71 million early votes have been cast
that's more than half of the total
number of votes
in 2016. of the 71 million
48 million roughly have been mailing the
rest have been in person
now of those 48
of early votes are democrats 29
are republicans you might see that and
say beautiful joe biden's got this
remember of those polled
who have not yet voted overwhelmingly
they support trump
so we have to understand a lot of the
early vote
seems to be going for biden those
waiting to vote on election day
seem to be leaning trump it is not going
to be
the blowout that these early numbers
suggest we all must vote
texas is really voting 87
of the total 2016 turnout has already
been cast
in texas very much suggesting
blow it out of the water record turnout
in texas and i look forward to seeing
those numbers
we have a very backwards country in many
ways
a lot of you know that we've seen that
during the last seven eight months of
the global pandemic we have a pandemic
and donald trump supporters and right
wingers go after
the doctor telling us how to fight the
pandemic dr anthony fauci
needing full-time armed security anthony
fauci's daughters
needing security well now cbs has had to
fire a higher
rather full-time security for 60 minutes
correspondent leslie stahl
because trumpists are threatening her
life because
she asked questions of donald trump
during the 60 minutes interview that
aired on sunday night
an unidentified suspect called leslie
stahl's home on thursday
threatened her family said something
about neo-nazis
this is a 78-year-old reporter who did
her job
trying to keep the president accountable
as we should have the press doing in any
viable democracy and she now needs
security guards at her house
the trumpists instead of seeing their
dear leader
crumble under basic questioning and
saying wow maybe i shouldn't support
trump
they instead go after the interviewer
and she now needs security at her house
whenever she goes out in public because
trump supporters
are furious that she did an interview
that wasn't
gushing praise like what sean hannity
and maria bartoromo and rush limbaugh
and others do
is this what it means to win to be so
triggered
that you have to threaten a nearly 80
year old woman for asking
questions of the president this is what
happens though
when the president spends more than a
full presidential term
attacking the media calling them fake
and phony
and the enemies of the people people
start going after reporters
the media of course are not infallible
the media must be held accountable
media get things wrong and they should
have to issue corrections when they do
but this has gone too far guys trump
rose to power
in this wave of nationalism and
anti-press and anti-free speech
sentiment and these are the results
they've baked the cake now they've got
to eat it and i hate to tell you
leslie stahl's interview wasn't even
particularly difficult they were simple
questions
mr president you said x defend it with
facts and trump's not able to do it
the fact that trump can't answer doesn't
mean that the interview was in any way
that much hardball
in other countries where elected
officials are frequently actually held
accountable by the press
that would not be considered a tough
interview just because trump won't stop
whining about it
doesn't mean it was actually tough it
just means trump can't handle it
now of course all right wing media
that is about law and order and free
spree
free speech and a free press i'm sure
right-wing media is denouncing these
threats against leslie stahl right
well i searched i couldn't find anyone
saying a word about it in right-wing
media
don't know why i wonder we need change
we need change we have to remove this
guy or things are going to get even
uglier there's no question whatsoever
and unfortunately in his removal things
may briefly get uglier
i've been talking about that for a while
i am worried
about what trumpists may be capable of
if their dear leader is soundly defeated
six days from now but it has to happen
and understand that the reason we're not
going to hear criticism
of leslie stahl getting death threats
from the right and from trumpists
is the same that we have people
following
these evangelical televangelist scammers
and making them multi-millionaires
it will only end when we break the cult
of personality
the michigan governor had a kidnapping
plot against her
thanks to donald trump directing his ire
against her
and trump couldn't even flatly denounce
the people who planned the kidnapping
of gretchen whitmer and meanwhile just a
final note on the 60 minutes interview
republicans and trumpists have been
slamming cbs
because they didn't air the full
interview which 60 minutes never does
the way 60 minutes is a news magazine
they don't air uncut interviews they
record an interview
and they cut it to tell a story along
with images and whatever else
the reality is trump looked better
because 60 minutes couldn't air trump's
entire interview
the full interview which trump released
on facebook i think it was or maybe
youtube
it makes him look worse he said even
crazier things that
cbs cut out in the 60 minutes interview
they didn't just edit the interview
so that it would fit on tv in the
allowed time
they edited it because trump was making
lunatic unverified claims and not
answering questions
60 minutes helped trump by editing down
the interview
what a backwards world we're living in
right now we're going to have more on
this
on the david pakman show instagram page
david pakman show you can also find me
on instagram
check out my latest tomato haul from my
urban garden by following me on
instagram
david.pacman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
douglas murray who is the best-selling
author of uh numerous books including
the madness of crowds the strange death
of europe
um it's great to have you on first and
foremost
very good to be with you david so we're
having this conversation
um just a few days before uh
a major election here in the united
states where there will be
uh either another four years of donald
trump or not there will be either
more uh republican control of the senate
or not and and really a lot of the next
two four six years in the united states
depends on the outcome of this election
we've seen in other sort of
western democratic allies
also sort of turning points or potential
inflection points in terms of a more
nationalist move or not i guess with you
where i would want to start is
what do you see as the state of
conservatism
right now and does that relate in any
way
to donald trump or is donald trump not
really part of that movement as
some traditional conservatives in the
united united states feel
uh it's it's a broad and complex
question and
it needs a broad and complex answer i
mean the short answer is
i think there has been a slightly
uncomfortable alliance in recent years
between
donald trump and the republican party
and the broader conservative movement in
the u.s
and whether that remains uncomfortable
becomes more uncomfortable or leads to
some terrible bloodletting will i
suppose depend on whether or not he
uh wins the election uh you know
not many days time i think that there
will be
if he doesn't win the election i think
there will be considerable uh
going over of exactly what it is that
happened
in the last four years and more in
american
republican politics that allowed for
this to happen if he does win of course
that all changes because everybody
migrates towards victors
and uh many people on the conservative
side in american politics many people
who are unsure for instance about
joining his administration or being
aligned with it in the first four years
may decide to make some peace with it
not everybody but some more people will
i don't think by the way that although
there is an attempt always by the
international media to
always draw sort of clear lines you know
we always like it to be you know the
world's turning left or the world's
turning right
and it never quite works like that i
think um there are trends you can see
but i don't actually think that donald
trump is part of any
broader conservative or right-wing
you know tendency he is whether you're a
admirer a detractor or
one of the confused people in the middle
i mean he is a very unusual force
i don't think he is uh in any ways
replicated in other countries he's not
he's not replicated in my own country
for instance in the united kingdom
um so it's very hard to draw broader
lessons away from donald trump
yeah i completely agree with you that
when i look at donald trump and i look
at what were
sort of more traditional conservative
principles i don't see anything there
sometimes by sheer odds he will stumble
across
something that sort of seems to fit and
for the most part i see kind of a
buffoonery in a dark room
stumbling around and sometimes hitting a
light switch but that
sort of gets to maybe a more
forward-looking question which is
i see you as someone who although
i think we would you know agree about a
few things
sort of but have significant political
disagreements i see
your brand of conservatism as something
that is almost directly antithetical
to most of what donald trump's policy
has been and my
my curiosity is do you think
that it makes sense for american
conservatives
to align with trump and sort of
try to use him to the extent they can to
accomplish for example
the confirmation of judges which which
really has been a major success for the
republican party under trump
because he'll nominate whoever they tell
him to nominate or is that
dangerous for the future of your own
movement well well
first of all i'm not a part of a
movement um conservatism is a very
tricky beast
to lasso because conservatives can serve
different things in different countries
what conservatives are conserving in
france is different
from what a conservative is conserving
in britain or belgium or denmark
let alone the united states or anywhere
else it's not quite the same to that
extent with
what's become known i think erroneously
as liberalism or leftism which tends to
have the same set of
demands it's a virtue and a vice of the
left
uh i think conservatism it's harder to
to
sum up like that as an international
trend you're right
by the way that donald trump is unusual
i don't think it's quite
correct to say that he has sort of
nothing in common with conservatism
in the united states i mean certain
obvious aspects of his
uh agenda are you know very conservative
um uh he he advocates
borders uh now i mean by the way that's
that didn't used to be you know seen as
being a particularly right-wing thing
but it has
it has become a conservative aspect to
be you know broadly against
open borders or you know uh more in
favor of
of of stricter immigration policies
um i guess i'm just not so sure that
that is actually what
makes him stand out as conservative
because when i see the democratic
proposals you know on daca for example
or as we get into details about it
i'm not seeing anybody advocating for
open borders free movement of
of labor i just don't see that well no
what has happened what has happened is
left in america and elsewhere has been
finding it increasingly hard
to react against a specific i think
i agree with you rather unusual
narrative on the left which nevertheless
the left is finding it increasingly hard
to resist i mean
you know obvious things um uh people who
come to the
the us illegally amnesties
these sorts of things there has become a
tendency i think it's it's
a shame uh for the immigration debate to
be seen in the left right demands it
didn't used to be of course uh people on
the left like uh
bernie sanders who used to recognize the
labor implications more of
of this sort of thing but just i don't
get stuck on board as the time being my
point is simply that
the the president has uh a stricter
policy than his opponents on immigration
rather boasts about it if anything he he
clearly advocates the law and order
agenda
um defending police rather than any
truck with people who say they want to
defund them uh
look i think as i say it's donald trump
is a very difficult person to draw
uh any clear lessons from because
obviously these things that i've just
mentioned many others are central to his
platform they've been central to
a lot of uh conservative voters voting
for him and yet he is a totally unusual
uh
beast in nature and i suppose that you
know one of the sadnesses
to me of the last four years is being
the unwillingness to learn the lessons
of what the electorate might have been
saying four years ago and voting for
somebody who
so many people had so many problems with
not least on his own side
if you voted in the united states would
you be voting for donald trump's
reelection
one of the great pleasures of not being
a citizen of the united states is not
having to weigh in in any way
on the fractional politics and so as an
outsider i will dodge that question
it's not a question you answer it's not
a question i answer
i'm not an american and i i don't
presume to
say how i would vote if i was an
american i wouldn't like to advise
any americans on how they should vote i
can see the
i can see a lot of um arguments each way
but i think unless you live in a country
and you pay taxes in a country and
experience the life in that country
i think you have to be very wary in
saying how people in that country should
vote
i'd love to think talk more about that
because like for example
i was born in argentina but i don't live
there but i'm very comfortable saying
if i did i would not have voted for the
current president or
you know in israel i would not be a
supporter of benjamin netanyahu or in
the uk i would not be a supporter of
boris johnson
and you know i'm not suggesting to
anybody else that i know more than them
or telling them how to vote but what
why is it that you find it inappropriate
to comment on something like that
we're a few days out for an election i
write on these issues but i don't like
to opine on how people should vote i
i just don't do it that's interesting
you know it's just a principle on it i
primarily think that out you know
outsiders in the country shouldn't
do that and what is the principle that
leads you to that conclusion
well i think i just said it i i don't
think that if you don't live in the
country don't pay taxes and much
more that you really should go around
advising people in any way how to vote
which obviously saying how you would
vote in the country
that does that but i think i mean the
one thing i would say is obviously
it's a it's a um it's it's a very tricky
situation that
your country the united states is in now
and um
uh i think that it's a very serious time
not
just to do with donald trump i think is
a very serious time in american history
and
a difficult corner that you're at to the
extent
that um there is a sort of
wing of uh the electorate
and this exists significantly in
online circles that cross country lines
you see
a sort of coalescing around
certain ideas about identity politics
and free speech suppression sometimes it
includes discussions of
tech monopolies or social media networks
sometimes the idea of a culture
war is is sort of raised i think you
sort of understand the the
the sort of umbrella that i'm referring
to
how important do you think that is in
relation
to what we sometimes consider the sort
of
major policy debates around things like
health care you mentioned immigration
foreign policy
are these do they overlap significantly
are these groups of people that are
concerned with very very different
things and
aren't as worried about those big policy
questions what's the interaction there
all of these things shift don't they all
the time foreign policy in particular
which you mentioned is a good example
there are there are parties that have
been very interventionist in the united
states and in the united kingdom in my
lifetime
which within years become relatively
isolationist you know all of these
things shift around
no political party remains totally
static albeit they like to give out the
impression very often they do
um and i think that it's very hard to
draw these trends across borders
i think you're i think one one thing
that is happening in all of our
countries clearly is that there is this
um uncomfortable disconnect going on
between the
the let's say the traditional political
wars which have always gone on and which
always will go on
and then these these larger you might
even say to some extent
deeper uh sort of identity issues that
are going on underneath everybody
these ones are um and some people call
these culture wars
and much more these are very um
tricky things for politics to address
because you can do them sort of glibly
you can sort of
nod to them um but most politicians find
them very
dangerous to touch that's certainly the
experience in my own country the british
politics is that
there are these deep issues which
occasionally i think of them like a sort
of
geezer they uh i i don't mean it in the
cockney uh
a guy ritchie sense by the way uh i mean
that there's a type of giza thing that
happens where
a moment allows the jet to come up
and suddenly everybody notices it and
you notice what's going on underneath
one of the interesting things that
happens uh with the interaction of
politics with what you describe is this
sort of online
world is that these things occasionally
erupt and people can sort of refer to
them they don't know what to do with
them otherwise
i mean you can have an issue oh i don't
know there'll be a specific
um piece well i mean i think cancel
culture is an interesting one to think
about where you've had
online now for a couple of years there
have been you know all of these uh
debates happening about does one have a
right to speak at a college
or or not and what does it mean if there
are protests and what about their speech
and then it bled over to where donald
trump has sent some of his wildly
capitalized tweets where he talks about
cancel culture
it's sort of pushed slightly above the
surface
into something trump is talking about is
that maybe an example
yes it is it is it's not a bad example
uh
i i would say again it's it's a it's a
good example in some ways because
you have that row about that specific
thing for instance should x person
speak at y venue yes but you but
we struggle with this question of for
instance why are so many people in our
time
finding it so incredibly hard to hear a
contrary opinion
what would the limits of opinion be can
they be in the public sphere the same
thing that they are online these are all
questions that we've been forced to
more or less think about and very
imperfectly address
because of the strange online world
which we all live with
we're going to pause my conversation
with douglas murray there the full
interview will be available on our
youtube channel very soon at youtube.com
the david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so you really have to see this to
believe it a long time viewer ned
sent me this clip and it is unbelievable
rudy giuliani went on fox business
yesterday
to again tell his wild conspiracies
about how
hunter biden flew from california
3 000 miles to the east coast to drop
off three laptops at a repair shop run
by a legally blind guy
and got off the plane drunk and drove to
the repair shop and then never picked up
the laptop
so the repair guy looked at his private
emails and then sent them to the fbi
that completely ridiculous story rudy
was on fox business to talk about
and it's all so ridiculous that even the
fox interviewer
who goes by the name kennedy actually
had to push back a little bit because
what rudy was saying
is so absurd and when she brings up
rudy giuliani acting sort of like
christopher steele of the steele dossier
rudy loses it starts demanding an
apology
you have to see this we're gonna jump in
several minutes in
rudy's been ranting for about three four
minutes completely incoherently
and kennedy starts to sort of question
are these laptops even really hunters
is this stuff really hunters and it
starts to get a little bit ugly take a
look
hunter biden allegedly dropped the
laptop off in april 2019.
i i i believe that completely um
but you only came in possession of this
ten days ago
so they've just been floating around for
a year and a half so how do we know
that these laptops if you have cracked
the encryption how do we know that other
people haven't
and placed some of this stuff on here
especially the most salacious stuff
when will you show the evidence to prove
that these are unadulterated
devices i gave it i gave it all to the
new york post and they've done their own
separate verification of it with
independent experts
and they came to the conclusion that
it's his hard drive
there are internal uh pieces of
information here
that only he could have that i know from
my investigation
okay so kennedy starting to ask
reasonable questions
and then keeps getting more and more on
rudy's nerves and
kennedy then says you know we're gonna
have to look into this ourselves because
it's sort of sounding a little bit weird
rudy and then kennedy says
you're sort of playing the role of like
a christopher steele
rudy flips and demands an apology take a
look at this
you see 50 pictures all right come
here's what we'll do we will have uh the
people
in our news departments verify all of
this
because um it sounds like
there may be something here that is
fishy that is causing
americans it's giving the pause and
other stuff
that uh might have been completely
adulterated over the 18 months
and some could say that you were acting
like christopher steele
that that you were abstracting
information and
because you've got to be kidding me i
was acting i was acting like christopher
steele that's what it sounds like when
you
apologize you better apologize for that
i mean i've been i've been a united
states attorney associate attorney
general
mayor of new york city and a member of
the bar for 50 years
i've never been accused of anything and
you're accusing me of being christopher
steele
i'm accusing you of that's outrageous
that you would do that based on number
two
to christopher steele and that symbol
back and forth
between structure of justice and the
united states
is an outrageous defamation so that
escalated
very quickly it goes from rudy having
essentially seven minutes
to rant incoherently to rudy demanding
an apology
from the interviewer and accusing her of
defamation
you have to love it let's keep going and
rudy just keeps demanding apologies
of me of my reputation
every single thing is here and i want
you to look at it
and then you apologize to me
well you can you can you can come to my
office and you can look at it and
tomorrow night you can apologize to me
for saying on my christopher's deal
i told you there are underage girls
there there are
i told you there are documents that show
that he's getting 10
there are there are documents that show
that he's getting half
of what hunter gets there are and when
they're there i want you to apologize to
me okay because you just defend me
absolutely and that's outrageous because
you have no basis for that
i came on your show in good faith to
give you evidence
that is being withheld from the american
people and i get defamed
isn't that great rudy wants to be able
to peddle these obvious lies and these
ridiculous
disjointed conspiracy theories with no
resistance
any resistance even mild and meek
is not going to be allowed and kennedy's
doing her best not to allow
rudy to rant endlessly with no with no
questions being asked
then rudy decides we've got to end this
interview
that's outrageous all right are you
still working on behalf of the president
i think our interview
i think our interview is now over i
haven't even gotten
i don't talk to people or the part about
1994 in the video music awards
that was the last time you and i were on
camera and it's taken
this long and and these yeah and
beautiful photographs this may be the
last time we'll be on camera
because i don't let people call me
christopher steele i'm sorry
christopher seal is a criminal you're
asserting that i'm a criminal
eastern europe is a cesspool and
americans i didn't get them from eastern
europe i didn't get them from eastern
europe you are now
repeating lying propaganda from the
democratic national committee
and the crooked biden family i had
nothing to do with eastern europe
i got this from the the repair man who
corroborates it
yeah come on kennedy that's not fair he
didn't get the stuff from eastern europe
he got it from a legally blind guy who
didn't actually say he identified uh
hunter biden as the guy dropping off the
laptops but he saw a bow biden
sticker on the laptops and determined
that clearly was hunter biden
who dropped these laptops off to me 3
000 miles away from where he lives
you're not being fair to rudy by
allowing him to tell that story
what a world what a world we live in and
then here are just the last few moments
rudy attacking the interviewer as not
being informed
all right do you regret i have this is
this is hunter biden's
this is hunter biden's material it has
proven a hundred times over and i have a
voice recording of him
in which he talks about being in
business with the chinese spymaster
maybe you should play the recording
and see if i don't have it it's been all
over the internet today
and if you were better informed you
would have known that oh i've i've read
plenty about this
i have and it's it's have you heard the
recording that's been out there all day
of hunter biden
saying that he is in business
with the chinese spy master patrick ho
and that his big partner the richest man
in china
may be dead and that he and his father
may be called as witnesses
did you hear that one no we have not
been able to
verify large swaths of the material
that has allegedly covered because
that's because you don't want to verify
it i would love to hear your your
uh your sister your sister
your sister your sister and entity the
new york post has verified it
it took five days to do it yeah i had i
have the opinion
from the people you think they're
printing
you think they're printing false
material you think rupert murdoch would
let them print false material
heavens now just because i gave it to
them and there's the sort of
catch to this entire thing it's not
about
let them print knowingly false material
it's about printing unverified
speculative material and the answer is
of course that's what the new york post
does and then
fox news opinion people use it to say
hey
this was reported by the new york post
giving them sort of
a veneer of uh plausible deniability
it's just hilarious
and really this is no big praise of
kennedy this is just
again it's like the people who are
criticizing leslie stahl for being
you know too tough on trump in any other
country with a free press i mean okay
north korea you're not going to get it
but in other countries with the free
press
presidents are much more regularly
exposed to tough questioning and
any mild questioning rudy just doesn't
want
and uh rudy just just think as we have
six days now left until this election
rudy is on that list along with jared
kushner
and ivanka kaylee maganani don jr
that is the list of people who hopefully
after tuesday we never have to hear from
again
that is as much as i'm incentivized to
remove trump
because we need somebody to start riding
the ship i am also very incentivized by
getting
all of these clowns off at until they
get deals to be
contributors to fox news of course at
least temporarily
off of the airwaves as people involved
in government really really insane stuff
but at least to the extent that kennedy
caused rudy to implode
nicely done nicely done but don't go too
far praising her
uh because she is still you know who she
is
so some people might find this
interesting or maybe depressing
remember how a couple of weeks ago i
mentioned
i had a coveted test and the reason i
had a covered test
is uh when i got back from our show
vacation i was in martha's vineyard
i was having some headaches and
tiredness which could be nothing
could be covered could be allergies
could be something else altogether
so my doctor initially said just because
we really don't want to miss it let's
first do a covid test
and rule that out we don't want you
walking around contagious if this isn't
allergies if it's
coronavirus so we did the covid test
it was negative okay good we ruled that
out
so then my doctor said let's just get a
bunch of standard blood work
uh we'll we'll check your blood counts
we'll check for infections we'll check
liver function because martha's vineyard
has a lot of ticks
uh let's rule out lyme disease i wasn't
aware of having been bit by a tick but
seems smart martha's vineyard and some
of those islands i think block island
nantucket
i think there's a heavy heavy amount of
tick uh
flying around walking around there do
ticks fly i'm not even sure
in any case i wasn't aware of being bit
by a tick but my doctor in an abundance
of caution said let's set up the blood
work i go in
there's no wait the phlebotomist sits me
down
great service i'm in there for five
minutes bing bang boom
nine vials of blood lighter i head out
and everything looks fine
that five minute visit was 1342 dollars
worth of blood work you have to see this
bill i got
which we're going to put up on the
screen for our visual audience
so you've got the puncturing of my vein
itself
that was 16 i guess that includes
the alcohol swab and the needle
and who knows whatever else some of the
blood tests are cheap
so for example like my basic blood count
was only 83 dollars
the liver function test which is the c
reactive protein that was 53
and then some of these tests are way
more money so since i was tired
we were looking at thyroid that one's
176 dollars
checking for lyme disease was 150
something called dna
rna zika i guess just testing for zika
virus
that was uh almost 500
and in total this was 1342
uh out from which my insurance
negotiated
a big discount for themselves and paid a
portion of it
leaving me with a 75
uh copay i guess you would say for the
blood work
this is another one of those examples of
a fundamentally broken
system and there are so we could do an
hour on each of these aspects
the huge sticker prices to account for
insurance companies negotiating
discounts to account for people without
insurance or people who never end up
paying
huge sticker price and then negotiating
down
five minutes in the hospital
theoretically thirteen hundred dollars
for someone
seventy five dollars for me because i
pay
500 a month for my insurance in other
words
when i got my appendectomy i mentioned i
had to pay my full two thousand dollar
uh deductible i paid 500 bucks a month
for insurance to have the privilege
of only owing 2 000 for my appendectomy
here i am paying 500 a month in
my health insurance premium to have the
privilege
of only owing 75 dollars for the blood
work
and of course all of this is a complete
disconnect
from the real actual cost of these
things
trash broken system uh
and we i mean listen i wish i could say
joe biden wins and we fix it but
we know it's much bigger than that joe
biden wants a public option and to
negotiate some drug prices
we need a much bigger systemic change
it's worse with trump
but this is going to be i mean i i don't
want to be pessimistic but
i think in the best case we've got a
decade before we really make
substantial change to this system uh and
we'll be talking about that more for
sure once we know
who will be steering the ship for the
next four years we have a voicemail
number that number
is 2192davidp here's a question via
voicemail about the swearing-in of amy
coney barrett that i actually received
from a number of
people take a listen hey david you're
from california
hey so um coney barrett got uh short one
in
but um what's interesting is why is
clarence thomas square versus the chief
justice
what's that about yeah you know a lot of
people ask this typically
it would be the chief justice swearing
in uh
you know a president a new supreme court
justice etc which would be john roberts
john roberts didn't do the swearing-in
of amy coney barrett it was clarence
thomas thomas instead
now i did a bunch of research to see if
there was anything definitive about why
that was i wasn't able to find anything
other than a lot of people speculating
and the primary speculation was john
roberts
takes more seriously avoiding what look
like politicized events
and a haphazardly thrown together
nighttime event at the white house
during a hundred year global pandemic
may have rubbed john roberts more the
wrong way
than it rubbed clarence thomas the wrong
way and that's the consensus
speculation that i found although i
found nothing definitive and
maybe we'll learn something more about
that upcoming but yes many of you
and i and many others wondering aloud
about what the deal was with that
on today's bonus show we will talk about
russia ordering a national mass
mandate coronavirus is out of control in
russia
we will talk about those two right-wing
operatives
jacob wall and jack berkman indicted
in a second state for voter suppression
schemes
i thought it was the left that was going
to do the voter fraud and a michigan
judge has
struck down um a ban on the open
carrying of guns at polling places on
election day
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video